[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في ساعه الاخباريه
مفصله من العربيه نبداها بالعناوين
بشان التسليم
احتياجات اوكرانيا العسكريه
بعدم التمسك بالقتال في المدينه
[تصفيق]
منظمه العفو الدوليه
يعاني من اضطرابات النفسيه مؤكده
باريس ومدن فرنسيه اخرى على موعد اليوم مع
مظاهرات عارمه ضد رفع سن التقاعد
اهلا بكم
امس الجمعه
في هذا سياق مشاهدينا قالت السفيره
الاوكرانيه لدى الولايات المتحده اقصانا
ماركوفا لشبكه السي ان ان قالت ان بلادها
بحاجه الى دبابات الان واضافت ماركو ماركو
فا ان الوقت مساله جوهريه في عمليه
التسليم اوكرانيا الدبابات الغربيه قبل ان
تسونال روسيا اي هجمات جديده كما اكدت ان
اوكرانيا بحاجه الى هذه الدبابات حتى
يتسنى لها استباق الهجمات الروسيه التي
تخطط لها بهدف التوسع خلال الربيع
موقف واشنطن الذي ظهر من خلال تصريحات
وزير الدفاع لايت اوستن يدعموه تصريح جديد
لرئيس الامريكي الذي قال ان اوكرانيا
ستحصل على كل ما تحتاجهم من المساعدات
العسكريه ياتي ذلك عقب عدم تمكن وزراء
دفاع في نيتهم الاتفاق على تسليمه يبدا
دبابات ثقيله وكان وزير الدفاع الامريكي
صرح عاقبه الاجتماع في قاعده المانيا بان
قرار تزويد قوه الاوكانيه بدبابات اليوم
هارد لم يتخذ بعد ما قد يطيل امر
المناقشات في هذا الشان للحصول على ضوء
الاخضر من المانيا
وعلى الرغم من فشل حلفائك في الاتفاق على
تسليم هدبابات ثقيله خلال اجتماع رانشتاين
في المانيا نقل عن وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
اريكس رزقوف قوله ان القوات الاوكرانيه
ستتدرب على دبابات اليوبارد اثنين
الالمانيه في بولندا وفي حديث لمحطه صوت
امريكا الناطق بالاوكرانيه وصف رزني كوف
تلك التدريبات بالانجاز وان الامر تم بدعم
بولندا
بدبابات حديثه وقال زي الاسكي في خطاب
المصور ان اجتماع سيعزز صمود بلاده معبرا
عن ثقته في ان الحلفاء سيدعمونا كيف قدر
الامكان موقف مبدئي سيدعمونا اوكرانيا ما
دام ذلك ضروريا من اجل تحقيق انتصارنا اجل
لا يزال يتوجب علينا الكفاح من اجل تسلم
الدبابات الحديثه لكننا نوضح كل يوم انه
لا بديل عن اتخاذ قرار بشان تسليم الدبابه
خلاف الماني امريكي حول ارسال دبابات
لاوكرانيا
برلين تشترط ارسال امريكا دبابه ابرامز
لكيف لترسل دباباتها اليوم
المانيا وجود هذا الشرط لكن بيان
البنتاجون اكد
البنتاجون رد بان دبابه ازرق باهضه الثمن
وتحتاجه لصيانه الدقيقه
دبابه ابره تحمل محرك النفاثا يعمل بوقود
الطائره
دبابه ابرمز تحتاج احد عشر لترا من وقود
الطائرات لقطع مسافه ميل واحد
دبابه ابرامز تحتوي على معدات معقده يصعب
التدرب عليها
[موسيقى]
دبابه
تعمل بمحرك ديزل
[موسيقى]
تحمل مدفع عن عياره 120 ملم
تضم تقنيات تمنح مزيدا من الامان والقوه
نطاق منها
قادره على اختراق الدروع الاماميه للدبابه
السوفياتيه السنه تي 72 على مدى كم
على خلفيه اتخاذ المانيا قرار عدم تجويد
الاوكرانيين بدبابات اليوم وهرتجمع المئات
امام مكتب المستشار الالماني في برلين
احتجاج على القرار المظاهره دعت اليها
منظمه غير حكوميه اسسها اوكرانيون في
المانيا وجاءت تحت عنوان حرر الفهود اي
دبابات اليوبارد
ضوء اخضر والماني منتظر لاتاحه ارسال
الدبابات لبرج القتاليه الى اوكرانيا
وبالنظر الى حاله الحرب المستمره منذ ما
يقرب من عام واحد يجب ان نزن جميع
الايجابيات والسلبيات بعنايات فائقه فاروق
لتوريد هذا الطراز من الدبابات الا ان
الصحفا المانيه عده اكدت اعتراض المستشار
الالماني على اتخاذي بلاده الخطوه الاولى
الحجام والالماني المتداول عن تقديم
الدبابات ليبرز او السماحي لدول الاخرى
بتزويدها غير مبرر امريكيا لا بل ان
المقارنه بين الدبابتين غير متوازنه وفق
مسؤولين امريكيين فدبابه الالمانيه متوفره
بجميع الدول الاوروبيه وسهله الاستخدام
ولا تسبب عرقله اللوجستيه وتستلزم ليبرت
تدريبا اقل مقارنه بدبابات ابرامز المكلفه
التي تستهلك وقود الطائرات بمعدل الثلاثه
جالونات لكل ميلا واحد كما تصعب الصيانه
المرتبطه بتشغيلها هذا التركيز على دبابات
لبرد الالمانيه الصنع سببه كذلك امتلاك
الحلفاء المئات منها ما قد يخفف العبء على
بلد بعينه فبولاندا مثلا ترغب بارسال 14
دبابه من هذا الطراز لكنها تصطدم بمعارضه
المانيه واذن مسبق قد يكون مطلوبا
[موسيقى]
يذكر انه تم بالفعل ارسال دبابات الى
اوكرانيا لكنها قديمه وتعمل بذخيره من
الحقبه السوفيتيه اوشكت على النفاذه لذلك
ياتي تشديد الرئيس الاوكراني على ضروره
امدادهم بدبابات حديثه تستخدم ذخيره غربيه
اكثر وفره ما يمنحهم قدره الماموله على
قلب الموازين
في التوافق حول ارسال الدبابات الالمانيه
كيف تنظر اليه اوكرانيا
نعم بالفعل يمكن قراءه يعني ما حصل بالامس
من ناحيه الناحيه الاولى هو حتى هذه
اللحظه ليس هناك قرار او لم تتخذ المانيا
قرار
بتزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات ليو بارك وحتى
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه هناك خمسه دول
اوروبيه تريد تزويد اوكرانيا بهذه
الدبابات ولكن تنتظر موافقه المانيا يعني
الناحيه الثانيه هي ردود الفعل الشعبيه
يعني راينا بالامس حمله كبيره عبر وسائل
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ضد المستشار
الالماني
بعض صفحات اوكرانيه بدات تصففه بانه داعم
للحمل الروسيه يعني وصلت للحد الى اتهامه
بدعم الحمله همم الروسيه والغاز الروسي
لاوكرانيا وحتى يعني
تم نشر بعض الصور وعليه يعني حرف زاد وهو
شعار الحمله الروسيه يعني هناك راي عام
اوكراني يرفض بشده وهناك انتقاد كبير يعني
ما حصل همم في يعني من تعنت المانيا اعطاء
الدبابات الى اوكرانيا انما انما يعني
المواقف الرسميه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
وفي ساعه متاخره من الليل كان له موقف ان
يعني اوكرانيا حققت خرق متفائل هذه كلمته
في موضوع تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات نيوبارت
وانه يمكن لبعض الدول ان تبدا بتقديم جنود
اوكرانيين على استخدام هذه الدبابات منذ
بدايه الفتره المقبله ربما
على هولندا التي حدث بخطوات استثنائيه في
حاله
المانيا كما يوصف همم هناك ايضا انتظار
لما ستفر عنه مشاورات مستقبليه ايضا بين
الحلفاء في هذا الموضوع صحيح محمد
نعم نعم يعني وحتى يعني تم تشكيل لجنه
اتصال يعني مشتركه بين الدول الاوروبيه
واوكرانيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لاستمرار الحوار وادي الجانب الاوكراني
وحتى الرئيس الاوكراني قال اننا لم نتوقف
عند هنا بلسا نقاتل وسنكافح من اجل الحقوق
على هذه الدبابات ولا ننسى ان يعني هناك
بعض الدول مثلا فنلندا كانت هي الدوله
الاولى التي اعلنت انها مستعده لتزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات هولندا قالت في اكثر من
موقف انها ستزود اوكرانيا بدبابات حتى لو
رفضت المانيا هناك قرار مجمع ولكن هناك
نقطه اساسيه وهي بعيده عن الاعلام لماذا
الان يعني المانيا وهناك بعض التردد من
قبل بعض الدول وهي لتامين وصول هذه
الدبابات بطريقه سليمه وامنه الى خطوط
التماس الى ساحات دون ان تكون روسيا
باعتراضها وتدميرها خلال فتره نقلها لذلك
هناك خطوات مسبقه اولا وهي وهو ما يتداول
هذه المعلومات خاصه لانها من يعني بعض
الاشهر يعني في وزاره الدفاع ما حصل وهو
ان الخطوه الاولى التي الجميع ينتظرها هو
وصول منظومات صواريخ باتريوس الى اوكرانيا
طيب في شان متصل ايضا في الاخبار انا
مسؤول الامريكيه النصح الاوكرانيين بعدم
الاستماته في الدفاع بخبط والتفرغ
والتركيز على همم الهجوم جنوبا في الربيع
بالتاكيد هل تلقى او يلقى هذا المقترح
قبولا في الداخل الاوكراني
يعني الجانب الاوكراني عاده يتلقى جميع
النصائح ولكن يتخذ ويكون ما يعني
القرارات هي ما تطلبه ساحه المعركه مثلا
الجيش الالكتروني عندما بدا بضرب مدينه
كان هناك رسائل من الجانب الغربي انه يعني
بعد ايام روسيا بضم هذه المقاطعات ربما
سيكون هناك رد فعل ولكن الجانب الاوكراني
يستمر في الخطه التي وضعها والان هناك
تحرر كبير في يعني في مقاطعه الجانب
الاوكراني او الجيش الاوكراني يقوم به
هجوم كبير للدخول الى منطقه الكريمينيا
وقام بالامس بشكل
الاوكراني الذي تقدم حوالي 6 كيلو مترات
عن نقاط السابقه ولكن الضغط كبير لان
الجيش الروسي لا يستخدم
مجموعات كما تسمى مجموعات من التخريبيه هي
التي تقوم بالاقتحام والدخول الى بعض
المناطق وتشتبك بشكل كبير مع قوات لبنان
شكرا لك من كيف كنت معنا الصحفي محمد
البابا تحياتي محمد
ميدانيه مشاهدينا قال زعم الدنيا
تحسن كثيرا يحدث هذا في وقت النصح مسؤول
امريكيين بعدم السماد في الدفاع عن مدينه
داعياهم بالتركيز على شنه هجوم مضاد في
الجنوب وراى المسؤول الكبير في اداره عين
ان الاولويه المعطي القتال في بخمه تعقيل
اوكرانيا في مهمتها الاساسيه للتحضير
لهجوم الاستراتيجي ضد روسيا في جنوب
البلاد خلال فصل الربيع مضيفا ان اطاله
مده القتال بخم التعزيز وضع الروسيه التي
تمتلك وامكانات مدفعيه اكبر وافضاليه في
عدد الجنود المسؤول الامريكي يستغرق
بالقول ان انتصار روسيا
لن يغير مجرى الحرب مطالبنا المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين بتشكيل وحدات عاليه الكفاءه
لشن هجوم الجنوب
صنفت واشنطن المجموعه الروسيه الخاصه
منظمه الاجراميه عابره للحدود وفقما كشف
عنه المتحدث باسم الامن القومي في البيت
الابيض جون كيبير المتحدث واعلن في هذا
السياق ان روسيا ارسلت نحو 50 الف مقاتل
من فاجنر الى اوكرانيا
في الدفاع عن نفسها ستقوم وزاره الخزانه
لتصنيف كم منظمه اجراميه الدوليه مهمه
هذا ورد مؤسسه مجموعه
على تصريحات البيت الابيض نيته بتصنيف
فاجنر على انها منظمه الاجراميه دوليه
واصفا امريكيين بانهم زملاء في هذه الحاله
واكد بريكوجين بلهجه ساخره ان مجموعه
امريكيين اصبحوا بمثابه زملاء مضيفا الى
انه من الان فصاعدا يمكن تسميته علاقتنا
التعاونيه بتفكيك الجرائم العشائريه كما
قال
تحركات روسيه غير متوقعه للتصيد
وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
التحرك مسافرا الى كيا سيف سرا للتقبي
برنس مع الرئيس جنسكي وكبار قادته الاسبوع
الماضي واعرض عليهم معلومات وتوقعات
الاستخبارات للمخططات الروسيه العسكريه
المحتمله في الاسابيع المقبله وفقا لمسؤول
امريكي
سفر المدير بيرد الى كيف حيث التقى
بالنظرائه في المخابرات الاوكرانيه وكذلك
بالرئيس الزنسكي وعزز دعمنا المستمر
لاوكرانيا في دفاعا ضد العدوان الروسي
خلال زيارته لاوكرانيا ليست معروفه لكنها
تشبه المعلومات التي قدمتها الاستخبارات
الامريكيه لاوكرانيا سابقا والذي ساهمت
بفشل روسيا في الاستيلاء على مطار انطونيو
برنس
تنتهي معظم الصراعات بالمفاوضات لكن هذا
يتطلب جديه من الجانب الروسي في هذه
الحاله لا اعتقد اننا نراها
اهميه زياده اوكرانيا
في موسكو وشغل منصبا في الخارجيه ويعد من
اهم خبراء الحكومه الامريكيه في الشان
الروسي وفهم عقليه
روسيا وعسكريا ومنصبه الاستخاره يجعل
معلوماته بالنسبه لاوكرانيا بمثابه الكنز
وعمر العربيه
معنا من مصر مشاهدينا ممارسه العربيه
كاتطيع ما اهلا بك كاتيا هل رصدت المزيد
بالرصد المزيد من ردود الفعل حول
نيه الولايات المتحده لتصنيف باغنا منظمه
اجراميه عابر الحدود
زملاء له اا طبعا حتى الان لا يوجد اي
تصريحات رسميه او رد رسمي من السلطات في
روسيا كما تعلم احمد رانر بدات بالعمل
بشكل رسمي وافتتح مركز لها في مدينه سان
بطرس همم برج في الرابع
همم كانت طبعا على الارض قد ساهمت بشكل
كبير بتحرير مدينه السادات همم التي
شاهدناها همم
منذ فتره قليله طبعا كانت الدفاع الروسيه
ولاول مره تذكر في بيانها وتخرج ببيان
توضيحه بان عمليه تحرير هي كانت على
المشترك همم وهو كان اعتراف ولاول مره من
بشكر رسمي بالشهود قوات بعضها الخاصه على
الارض لذلك الان احنا في ترقب لا نعلم اذا
سيكون هناك بالفعل همم بيان رسمي ان
الكريم او من الدفاع يدافع عن هذه المنظمه
الخاصه التي ادت تقاتل في العمل همم مع
القوات الروسيه همم في العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه اوكرانيه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه او الحكومه الروسيه
التي تعاون بشكل كبير على همم قواتنا او
على مجموعه باكنار في تحقيق انتصارات في
سياق الحرب الدائره في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الشيشانيه او القوات الانسانيه او حتى من
المتطوعين روسيا لم تنكر ان هناك عدد كبير
من المتطوعين همم بالاضافه الى القوات
التي تم التعبئتها انضمت القتال هناك
ايضا بشكل كبير بتحرير مدينه في وقت
السابق لذلك
على قوات باتنه التي لديها خبره خاصه في
القتال كما يتحدث قائد بابنرفوش بشكل خاص
وبالاخص لان هذه القوات ليست فقط قوات
خاصه هي ايضا من الذين تم اخراجهم من
السجون من
المحكومين يعني من المحكومين الذين تم
اخراجهم وتجميدهم الان في القوات
تحياتي كثيره
اكد نائب وزير الخارجيه اتفاقا مسؤوليه
مجموعه السبع على مراجعه المستوى الحد
الاقصى المفروض على اسعار
المقبل واضاف ان التاخير الموعد
سببه الوقت لتقييم السوق بعد التسعيرات
الاخيره للمنتجات النفطيه الروسيه وكانت
مجموعه السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي واستراليا
اتفقت الشهر الماضي على وضع حد اقصى لسعر
الصادرات البحريه
في اطار العقوبات وتهدف الخطوه الى الحد
من العائده الروسيه مع ضمان استمرار موسكو
في امداد السوق العالميه
يستعيد الاتحاد الاوروبي لفرض حزمه عاشر
من عقوبه على روسيا وافخالي وكاله رايترز
الوكاله نقلت على مسؤولين اوروبيين من
العقوبات الجديده تدخل حيزه تنفيذ الشهر
المقبل مع مروري عام على الحرب في
اوكرانيا
على الشعب الاوكراني خاصه نهر الميزان
التجاري ولسه بتضخم التي اضرار
وفقا لدائره الاحصاء الحكوميه الاوكرانيه
فقط ملقا التضخم في السوق الاستهلاكيه
لاوكرانيا حوالي 27% استمرت اسعار
المنتجات المستورده وتلك المصنوعه محليا
في اوكرانيا في الارتفاع بسبب اقتصاد
الحرب السلطات الاوكرانيه تعمل جاهده على
تنظيم ضبط مستوى التضخم في السوق
الاستهلاكيه خاصه بعد ارتفاع تكلفه
المنتجات المستورده والمصنعه في اوكرانيا
المهمه للحد من تصدير المنتجات الى الداخل
من ناحيه نتخذ عددا من الاجراءات لتوسيع
العرض ومن ناحيه اخرى يواصل البنك الوطني
التسعيره الثابت اما ثالثا نحافظ على
تكلفه اضافيه هامشيه ثابته على المنتجات
الغذائيه
والتضخم تواصل الاعمال التجاريه في
اوكرانيا العمل ومحاوله التمسك بالسوق
المحلي الا ان الامر يتطلب سياسات من ضمن
جديده من الدوله وادارات الاعمال تتوافقوا
مع حاله الحرب بامعاني النظر في ارفف
المحالي التجاريه ومحلات البقاله فالملاحظ
اختفاء بعض السلع منها ومع ارتفاع الاسعار
اتخذ المواطن كذلك تدابير جديده لاداره
اقتصاد الاسره مما تسبب بشكل مباشر في
انخفاض نسبه لقوه الشرائيه في السوق
الاوكرانيا
والسبب هو ارتفاع الاسعار ولا حط اختفاء
العروض الترويجيه
اخر كبديل فقط نتمنى ان تنتهي الحرب بشكل
اسرع يتوقع
الاقتصاد العالمي هذا العام بنسبه 1.7 لا
سيما بسبب العواقب السلبيه الناجمه عن
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا ارتفاع تكاليف
المعيشه والخطر الرئيسي للم معادي خلال
العامين المقبلين على الرغم من ذلك ووفقا
لوزيره الاقتصاد الاخرانيه يوليوسيفور
دينكو فان اقتصاده اوكرانيا ما زال صامدا
ويتكيف بنجاح مع ظروف الحرب وحتى مستوى
التضخم في اوكرانيا لا يزال تقريبا في ذات
المستوى بالمقارنه مع عدد من الدول
الاوروبيه حذيفه عادل العربيه كيف
نشاطنا مستمره فيها بعد الفاصل
كانت تبدا ترحيل مواطنها من اساءه واطفال
داعش من سوريا
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد تداعيات الحرب
الاوكرانيه لا تزال تضغط على اوروبا لجهه
التسليح وسطه وخايفه من اندلاع حرب وسعه
النطاق في هذا السياق اعلن رئيس الفرنسي
عن الخطوط العريضه لمشروع قانون يهدف الى
تحديث الجيش الفرنسي وتهيئته لمواجهه
التحديات والحروب شديده الحته
تسعى فرنسا الى زياده انفاقها العسكري
ليتناسب مع تحديات دوليه كبيره على راسها
الحرب في اوكرانيا مساءا اعلن عنها الرئيس
الفرنسي خلال لقائه مع قاده وافراد قوات
المسلحه في قاعده جويه جنوبيه البلاد لنا
الاستراتيجيه من اجل تجديد ادواتنا
العسكريه التي تصون حريتنا وامننا
وازدهارنا
وتنفقوا فرنسا حاليا على ميزانيه الدفاع
295 مليار يورو لكن مع اعلان مكروه سيرفع
حجم الانفاق بنحو الثلث ليصبح
413 مليار يورو بين عام 2017 و 2030 خطوه
لها دلالات كثيره
في اوروبا
وفي سياق الحربي الاوكرانيه دول عديده
تقدمت نحو هذا التوجه في اوروبا سبقت
المانيا جارتها فرنسا بخطوه الى الامام مع
اعلانها رفعها الانفاق العسكري الى 100
مليار يورو لكن المساله عندما تخرج عن
الرئيس الفرنسي لها ابعاد اكبر خصوصا وان
فرنسا قوه الردع النووي الوحيده في القاره
وعند الحاجه ستكون باريس خط المواجهه
الاول في وجه التهديد النووي فادي الدهوك
العربيه باريس
دعى المستشار الالماني والرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون الى تعزيز سياده الاتحاد
الاوروبي وذلك في مقال مشترك نشر قبل
يومين من انعقاد مجلس الوزراء الالماني
الفرنسي المشترك في قصر
ماكرون اكد ان الاتحاد الاوروبي امام
التحدي اساسي يقضي بضمان ان تصبح اوروبا
اكثر سياده وتملك القدرات الجيوسيه لارساء
النظام الدولي واعتبر ان على اوروبا
استثمار المزيد في قواتها المسلحه
وصناعاتها دفاعيه واوضحها ان السياده
الاوروبيه ينبغي ان لا تقاس بالمعايير
العسكريه فحسب بل بالقدره على الصمود
والتحرك بصوره الاستطلاعيه في المجالات
الاستراتيجيه
في بيانهم المشترك الى ان الاتفاق اتاها
حتى تغلب على قرون من الخصومات المريره
والحروب الداميه بين البردين في قلب
اوروبا
في ايران اعترف النائب مرتضى محمود ولد
عضو لجنه الامن القومي
محمد
يعاني منذ وقت طويل من الترابات النفسيه
وحكم عليه بالاعدام مرتين في محاكمه شكريه
غير عادله
براره وزاره الامن الايرانيه اعدام
المسؤول الايراني السابقه لرضا اكبر بانه
وفر معلومات سريه تتعلق بقدره طيران
العسكريه لبريطانيا واضافت الوزاره ان
اكبر الذي اعدمته قبل ايام وكان يحمل
الجنسيه البريطانيه قدم لبريطانيا ما
وصفتها بمعلومات سريه حول سبل التفاف
طيران على العقوبات واضافت الوزاره ان
لندن طلبت من اكبر تزميتها بمعلومات حول
الاجهزه الامنيه والسياسيه والعلماء
البارزين مثل العالم النووي محسن فخري
زاده الذي قتل قبل ثلاثه اعوام
تشهد محافظه مارب ومخيمات النزوح بشكل خاص
ارتفاع حاله سوء التغذيه وسط اوضاع
انسانيه ومعيشيه صعبه هذا وتعاني المرافق
الصحيه
من الجفاف وسوء التغذيه الذي افقده الحركه
والاوضاع المعيشيه الصعبه اليسرته تحول
دون توفير الغذاء المناسب
مستشفى
[موسيقى]
الا عنده 50 حاله اللسوء التغذيه تتم
معاينتها يوميا في مركز صحي واحد تحاله
بعضها للرقود فيما سجل مخيم الجفينه
المعدل الاعلى بمئه واحد 131 حاله لسوء
التغذيه الحاد العام الماضي
همم اريج ناصر من مخيم الجفينه تعاني من
سوء تغذيه مع مضاعفات عمرها شهرين وزنها
اثنين كيلو فاصل اثنين واكثر الناجحين
ياتون من مخيم الكفيناه ففي عام 22 من شهر
واحد لا نهايه عام 2022 معنا حاله تغذيه
من مخيم الكفيله 131 طفل طوابيره من
الاطفال بانتظار الخضوع لبرامج علاجيه في
وحدات صحيه تبنتها المنظمات الدوليه ثم
تخلت مؤخرا عن تشغيلها بحجه نقص التمويل
ما تزالوا تعملوا الى اليوم دون توفير
مستحقاتك وادرها الطبيه حالات التغذيه في
تزايد كل يوم في تزايد مستقبل كثير العديد
من الاطفال في بعض الاحيان نحول حالات
الركود حالات الوخيم ثلاث الى خمس حالات
ركوب همم في بعض الاحيان لا يستطيع القسمه
الداخلي استيعاب كل الاطفال اللي تتم
حالتهم
منظمات الدوليه من زياده حالات سوء
التغذيه تؤكدها الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
والمعيشيه في اليمن
ارقام هي الاكبر وتسجل لحالات سوء التغذيه
في اليمن ومعاناه هي الاوسع منذ بدء الحرب
مع تردد الوضع الانساني والمعيشي خصوصا في
مخيمات النزول محمود الحميدي لقناه
العربيه مارب
عاجل فقد اعلن وزير دفاع تركيا او وزير
دفاع تركي اذا يلغي زياره لنظيره السويدي
في السابع والعشرين من يناير بسبب
احتياجات ضد انقره
فيكم بمزيد من التفاصيل حاله وردي حول هذا
الموضوع
وزاره الخارجيه الكنديه موافقتها على
اعاده 60 كنديات و13 طفلا محتجزين في شمال
شرق سوريا منذ سنوات في اكبر
الاطلاق وقالت الخارجيه الكنديه ان
القراره يتعلق فقط في نساء واطفال
المجموعه وليس رجال الاربع الملاحقين
القضائيا من قبل الحكومه الكنديه ولم تحدد
الوزاره موعده اعاده النساء والاطفال
المعانيين ولم تقدم اي اشاره الى
الاجراءات القانونيه المحتمله التي يمكن
ان تتخذها ضد النساء عند عودتهن الى
الاراضي الكنديه
القامشلي معنا مراسل العربيه جمع كاش اهلا
بك يا جمعه في اي سياق جاءت هذه الخطوه
الكنديه ما الذي جرع الارض ودفع السلطات
الكنديه لتغيير موقفها من راعيها في سوريا
رجالها المجلسين بالجنسيه الكنديه من سجون
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه اضافه الى حوالي
24 طفل وامراه استعاده بعض من
امراتين طفلين الان لديه عدد تقريبا سته
نساء في من مخيم روج وايضا حوالي 13 طفل
هؤلاء تلقوا همم بعضهم طلقه اشعارات برغبه
الحكومه لكنديه باستعادتها تواصلنا مع
الاداره اذا فيها هناك ايضا تاكيد بان كان
تريد همم استعاده همم هؤلاء طبعا عمليه
اعاده همم الدواعش من الجنسيه الكنديه
تاتي معرض الضغوطات التي تمارسها يعني
الامم المتحده ومفوضيه حقوق الانسان نتيجه
الاوضاع الكارسيه
لا ادري ان كنت سمعتك بشكل صحيح هل قلت ان
هناك رجال اي ضد ابناء همم قائمه المرحلين
الى كندال خارجيه الكنديه تقول ان القرار
فقط بالنساء والاطفال وليس الرجال الاربعه
الملحقين قضائيا ايضا من الحكومه الكنديه
الكنديه المتواجدين في سجون قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه لكن هؤلاء لم يتلقوا اشعارات
من الخارجيه الكنديه لاعادتهم عمليه
الاعاده حاليا محصوره
بسته النساء و13 طفل متواجدين في مخيم روج
واحد من الرجال
الكندي المعروف باعلامي داعش هو صاحب
التسجيلات همم الشهيره في مدينه الرقه همم
طبعا همم تكون قد قبلته منذ حوالي عامين
وكان لديه هواجس من العوده الى كندا لانه
سيكون ملاحقه قضائيا وكان هناك معلومات من
محامي جون الكناديب بانه تم اسقاط الجنسيه
الكنديه على الرجال مشاكل كبيره في همم
حتى الحكومه الكنديه ربما لا تغامر باعاده
همم باعاده الرجال بسبب المخاطر ال- ال-
الامنيه وبقاء يعني معظمها هؤلاء الرجال
بتبني فكر داعش حتى يعني هذه اللحظه
فبالتالي الكره الحكومه قتلات تغامر
باعاده الرجال نعم شكرا لك يا دنيا
القامشلي كنت معنا مؤسسه العربيه جماعه
تحياتي جمعه
في سابقه بتاريخ لبنان في البرلمان
اعتصاما مفتوحا داخل مجلس النواب ان ابان
ملحم خلف ونجاه الصليبه بدا هذا التحرك
على الاقل في مبنى البرلمان احتجاجنا على
عدم انتخاب رئيس جمهوريه جديد حتى الان
ولا حتى نكون ملتينه وقاعدين بالمجلس لحتى
ننتخب رئيس عتمه البلاد وعتمه مجلس النواب
تعطيل المشترك فكان الدعوه بين ملح خلف
نجاه صليبه للبقاء داخل المجلس والمبيت
فيه للضغط من اجل عقد جلسات متتاليه
لانتخاب رئيس للجمهوريه
اليوم كانوا هو من ضمن الدستور ومن ضمن
القوانين الماده 74 والماده 75
والوطنيه بتحمل مسؤوليته وبتحمل نتيجه
قرارات
اعلن انه سيستمر حتى الجلسه المقبله
لانتخاب رئيس الا ان رئيس البرلمان نبيه
بري وبدل ان يدعو الى جلسه الانتخاب دعى
الى اجتماع للجان نيابه المشتركه
رئيس جمهوريه يعني في استهتار بمعانات
اللبنانيين من قبل البلد بشكل
والتيار الوطني الحر يعني اليوم لا عم
بيرشحوا حدا
ولا عم يقبلوا ينتخبوا حدا وعم بعطلوا
بنفس الوقت
جلسات انتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه وبيرجع
وتحديدا التيار الوطني الحر بيرجعوا
بيتباكو على ما يسمونه هن حقوق المسيحيه
المداخل المؤديه للمجلس اغلقها الجيش
اللبناني تحسبا لدخول متظاهرين الى محيطه
الجمهوريه وبندعي كل الشعب اللبناني بانه
ينزل على الشارع لهون شو بيكبر الارض
بتمنى من كل الشعب كله ينزل الضمان
بطريق ثوره ضعيف
ومقابله النواب وحتى الاعلام المعتمد في
البرلمان منع من تصويرهم خطوه اعتبرها
البعض عمليه تعتيم مقصوده لمحاولتي انقاذ
البلاد هذا تحرك سيستمر بحسب ما يؤكد
النواب لكن ما لا يمكن تاكيده ان ياتي
بالحل المنشود رغم ان التدهور وصل الى
اعلى مستوياته مع تسجيل رقم قياسي جديد
لانهيار العملاء ناهد يوسف العربيه بيروت
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد من المتوقع ان
تشهد تل ابيب والقدس ابيه وتظاهرات ضد
سياسه رئيس الوزراء بنيابه وعاقب
الاحتجاجات الحاشده التي شهدتها تل ابيب
ليله السبت الماضي قال زعيم المعارضه انه
سيشارك في التظاهر نهايه هذا الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
التي تعد العصب الرئيسي للحياه الاقتصاديه
لاسرائيل
ستؤثر وتهاجم الديمقراطيه تريد اضعاف
المحكمه العليا
للدوله ستمنع ايضا المواصلات ايام السبت
هذا يقلقني
الاسرائيليون يتخوفون من قرارات حكومه
نتنياهو التي تحاول فرض واقع جديد من خلال
اضعاف المحكمه العليا وفرض ايديولوجيا
اليمين المتشدد ما يؤثر على الحياه
اليوميه لدى سكانها ومن قرارات منع
المواصلات العامه في ايام السبت في تل
ابيب كخطوه غير مسبوقه
في اي دوله يريد اولادنا ان يكبروا
الاتجاه مقلق نشعر انه يخرج عن التوازن
الكثير من العمر
مشرق لاولادنا هنا اتمنى ان تتغير الامور
قريبا عشرات الالاف من تيارات مختلفه في
اسرائيل يواصلون الاحتجاج ويستعدون للخروج
غدا في تل ابيب للتعبير عن قلقهم من اكثر
حكومه يمنيه متشدده في تاريخ اسرائيل
وصفين
بالعدائيه
المحتمل هذا ما يمكن ان تتسبب به المواجهه
الداخليه مع حكومه نتنياهو اذا استمرت في
سياستها التصعيديه التي توصف هنا
بالديكتاتوريه
من تل ابيب العربيه
قال ايضا ان زياره نظيره السويدي الى
تركيا في السابع والعشرين يناير اصبحت لا
معنى لها او قيمه لها لذا والغيت
تشهد العاصمه الفرنسيه اليوم تظاهرات
الجديده من ساحه الباستيل في وسط باريس
الدعوه نقابات العمانيه
الى 64 عاما بحلول عام 2030
وتسريع عمليه رفع الحد الادنى سنوات
المساهمه في صندوق التامين التقاعدي
للحصول على معاش تقعدين كامل
فتحت الشرطه البريطانيه تحقيقا بعد ظهور
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشه سوناك في
مقطع فيديو داخل سياره ولا يضع حزام
الامان سوناتا اعتدى رعي الخطا لكن الجدل
لم يتوقف
اجباري ومن الضروري ان يربط كافه الركاب
حزام الامان في السياره مخالفه ذلك تفرض
على صاحبها غرامه قد تصل الى 500 جنيه
هذا ما تحقق فيه الشرطه اللانكشير بعد
ظهور رئيس الوزراء ريشه سوناك في فيديو لا
يرتدي فيه حزام الامان فيما سيارته تتحرك
سوناك اعتذر عن خلع حزام الامان خلال
التصوير مقطع لمتابعي على الانستغرام
واعتبره خطا في التقدير سونار قد يتلقى
غرامه ماليه على هذه المخالفه الجديده بعد
تغريمه 50 جنيه العام الماضي لخلقه قواعد
كورونا عندما كان وزير الماليه في عهد
حكومه برج جونسون
لا تشرع قانون
يوسف السكن
الثانيه غرامه الله بعد مخالفته القانون
مرتين في الحكومه البريطانيه الا اذا وجدت
الشرطه التبريرا المقنعا لعدم ارتداء حزام
الامان وذلك في الحالات الاستثنائيه
الصحيه المحدوده وهذا مستبعد في حاله
سوناك لا احد يستخفه بالتحديات التي
تواجهه بريطانيا من اقتصاد المتعثر وغلاء
المعيشه واضرابات تتسع حدتها والان ريشه
هناك الذي يقود البلاد في هذه المرحله
الحرجه في ازمه خاصه بسبب خلقه القانونه
خلال اداء مهامه وان لم تكن تابعتها واضحه
بعد
مصطفى زاروه العربيه لندن
حزب العمال في نيوزلندا ترشيحه وزير
التعليم كريزي كنز لمنصبي رئيس رئاسه
الوزراء ليحل محل رئيسه الوزراء جاسترا
التي تنحت عن منصبها ويتعاين على هيبتنز
الحصول على تاييد الرسميه من زملائه في
حزب العمال في البرلمان ليصبح رئيس
الوزراء الحالي والاربعين في البلاد
لحزب العمال نيوزلندي وبالتالي رئيس
الوزراء المقبل لنيوزلندا يمكنني ايضا ان
اؤكد انه اعتبارا من الوقت الذي اغلقت فيه
الترشيحات في الساعه 9:00 صباحا
الوحيد لهذا الدور
اعلن متحدث باسم الامم المتحده ان
الاستثناءات الاخيره من القيود التي
فرضتها حركه طالبان على النساء في
افغانستان ليست كافيه بالنظري الى التراجع
الهائل لحقوقهم وكان احد رفيع يضم نائبه
الامين العام الامم المتحده امين محمد
والامينه تنفيذيه للهيئه الامميه لشؤون
المراه قد اختتم زياره استغرقت اربعه ايام
لكابل وقد دهار للوقوف على وضع المراه في
ظل قرارات طالبا
[موسيقى]
حركه طالبان حكومه دون اعتراف دولي ولا
داخلي الا ان الحركه تمارس قمع الانسانيا
وسياسيا ومهنيا
قوانين مقيده فرضتها طالبان على المواطنين
الافغان الذين قبلوا بها مجبرين لا مخيرين
ماذا فعل الامم المتحده للتحذير من كارثه
انسانيه لانهيار سياده النظام القانونيه
فبعد سيطرتها على افغانستان علق الطالبان
دستور عام 2004 وعزلت جميع القضاه من هيئه
المحكمه وجردت مكتب المدعي العام من دوره
الرئيسيه بات القسم الذي ادلى به المحامون
والقضاء حبل مشنقه تعلقه طالبان على رقاب
المعرضين منهم لاحكامها كما تم اقصاء
النساء وتجريدهن من حقوقهن الاساسيات سواء
التعليمه او العمل او غيرهما من للحركه
التي لم تستثني النظام القانونيه
عمل وصفته الامم المتحده بالعمل التمييزي
الواضح حيث فصل الطالبان اكثر من 200 250
قاضيه ومئتين من المحاميات والمدعين
العامين في حين هرب العديد من القضيه من
البلاد او اختبائن باتت افغانستان تحت
نظام من غير مستقله ونظام حركه تستخدم
سلاح ضد من كل بتطبيق العدل اكثر من 10
مدعينين معظمهم من الرجال قتلوا على ايدي
مجهولنا ويقال ان العديد منهم ما زالوا
مختنئين
الامم المتحده قالت بان ما يتعرض له
العاملون في جهات انفذ القانون في مقصره
طالبان يتطلب تحركا فوريا من قبل المجتمع
الدوليه لوقفه تلك الممارسات التعسفيه
روان حمزه العربيه
[موسيقى]
موظف جوجل اثني عشر الف وظيفه وبهذه
الخطوات تنضم الى مجموعه من عمالقه
التكنولوجيا الاخرين مثل امازون وتويتر
الذين خلصوا عملياتهم بشكل واسع وسط تضخم
المتصاعد
بعد تويتر و ميتا بلات فورمز وامازون باتت
جوجل احدث الشركات التكنولوجيه العملاقه
التي تسرح العمال فوق الشركه الام لجوجل
الفابيت قامت جوجل بالغاء حوالي 12 الف
وظيفه ما يمثل اكثر من 6% من موظفيها
عالميا وهو القرار الذي قال الرئيس
التنفيذي لمجموعه الفا بيت انه يتحمل
مسؤوليته بالكامل تاثير هذه التغييرات على
حياه موظفي جوجل يلقي بثقله عليه وانا
اتحمل المسؤوليه الكامله عن القرارات التي
ادت بنا الى هنا
بفضل تماسك النشاط البحث كانت جوجل واحده
من شركات التكنولوجيا التي تمكنت من تجنب
اجراء تخفيضات كبيره في قوتها العامله
لفتره طويله في اكتوبر 2022 انخفضت ارباح
جوجل الى 27% حوالي 14 مليار دولار مقارنه
بالعام السابق كما انخفضت اسومها بنحو 30
بالمئه وهو الامر الذي دفع المستثمرين
لاجبار شركه الرائده على تبني استراتيجيه
اكثر صرامه للحد من الانفاق قطاع
التكنولوجيا يشهد طابات عن اقتصاديا كبيرا
ما ترك الموظفين العاملين في هذا القطاع
في حاله عدم اليقين والقلق على مستقبلهم
قطاع التكنولوجيا يشهد طبع اقتصاديا كبيرا
ما ترك الموظفين العاملين في هذا القطاع
في حاله عدم اليقين والقلق على مستقبلهم
اعلنا زعيم الاغلبيه الجمهوريه في
الكونغرس الامريكي ستيف سكارليس ان مجلس
النواب يخطط لتبني تشريع من الحزبين
ديمقراطي وجمهوري لانشاء فرقه عمل مهمتها
تحسين نظام كمبيوتر الطيران اما في ذلك
اضافه التحديثات لضمان استقرار ومرونه
وامني الرحلات الجويه
حضاره وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه جنت يلا
اننا من ان التخلف عن سداد الديون
الامريكيه سيؤدي الى ركود في الولايات
المتحده ما قد اكتسبب في ازمه ماليه
عالميه واضافت لنا لشبكه سي ان ان انه في
حال التخلف عن سداد الدين الامريكي فان
تكاليف الاقتراضي سترتفع اضافه الى انه
سيقبض دورا دولار عربي وصفه عمله احتياطيه
تستخدم في المعاملات في كل انحاء العالم
فضلا عن فقدان الكثير من الامريكيين
لوظائفهم
اعلن وزير خارج امريكا خلال زيارته لجامعه
شيكاغو ان المحادثات مع الصين خفضت التوتر
بين البلدين وعبر في الوقت نفسه عن قلقه
بشان تايوان مشيرا الى محاوله بكين عزل
الجزيره ولفت الى سلسله المناوره العسكريه
الصينيه خلال السنوات القليله الماضيه
واضاف بالامكان ان مساله تايوان تتعلق
مباشره بالولايات المتحده وبقيه العالم
مشيرا الى دوري الجزيره المهم بالنسبه
للاقتصاد العالمي
في شان صيني اخر قالت السلطه
انتهت وذلك بتزاني مع حركه تنقلات واسعه
داخل الصين بسبب عطله راس السنه القمريه
ادى الى زياده المخاوف من عوده تفشل وباء
بسبب الزحام في وسائل المواصلات
من مرحله لاخرى تحاول الصين تجاوز عقبه
كورونا وبخطا مثقله باعباء الوضع الصحي
تعلن عن انتهاء ذروه موجه تفشل قاسيه
فاوفقا لنائبه رئيس الوزراء الصيني صارت
الجائحه بشكل عام في البلاد عند مستوى
منخفض نسبيا
عدد الحالات الحرجه في المستشفيات تتناقص
بشكل مترد والجائحه اصبحت عند مستوى
المنخفض لكن مهمه الانقاذ لا تزال ثقيله
الاعلان الرسمي عن تحسن الاوضاع الصحيه
يتزامن مع عطله راس السنه القمريه الجديده
وفي يوم يعد احد اكثر ايام السفر ازدحاما
منذ فش الجائحه عام 2019
يتخوفوا لبعض من زياده اخرى في عدد
الاصابات بسبب حركه السفر والتنقلات
تخوفات لم يخفها الرئيس الصيني في جنبينج
الاسبوع الماضي لا بد من بدل المزيد من
الجهود لتحسين رعايه الطبيه للفئات
المعرضه للاصابه بالفيروس في المناطق
الريفيه ومعالجه مواقف في الوقايه من
الاوبئه في هذه المناطق
التصريحات الرسميه الصينيه تتزامن وتوجه
اليابان بخفض تصنيف كورونا الى فئه
الانفلونزا خلال الربيع القادم
حريمي
على تعزيز المناقشات بين الخبراء حول
خطوات اعاده تصنيف فيروس كورونا الجديده
5 في هذا الربيع ارقام المؤسسات الصحيه
العالميه تتماشى مع تحذيرات منظمه الصحه
العالميه حول تطورات كورونا في العالم حيث
اشارت الى ارتفاع نسبه الوفيات الى 20% في
الفتره ما بين ديسمبر الماضي ويناير
الجاري مقارنه بالايام الثمانيه والعشرين
التي سبقت هذه الفتره الى جانب انخفاض
نسبه الاصابات بنحو 7%
اما السلطات الصحيه الصينيه فتواصل سعيها
لاحتواء المرض كان اخره حصول شركه
سينوفارم الصينيه على موافقه الاستخدام
لقاح ضد متحول اوميكرون
علي السمان العربيه
الروسيه تتقدم في باخ موت و مسؤول امريكي
ينصح الجيش الاوكرانيا بعدم التمسك
بالقتال في المدينه
[تصفيق]
منظمه العفو الدوليه تحذر من اعدام متظاهر
ايراني يعاني من اضطرابات النفسيه مؤكده
باريس ومدن فرنسيه اخرى على موعد اليوم مع
مظاهرات عارمه ضد رفع سن التقاعد
الاخباريه مشاهدينا كونوا بالعافيه
[موسيقى]